en cette 14e journée de la guerre il y a
toujours foule à la gare d'el vif les
informations sont difficiles à obtenir
il ya le chaos mais il ya aussi beaucoup
de gens qui sont là pour aider que ce
soit les gens qui arrivent d'autres
régions de l'ukraine où ceux qui tentent
de partir en direction de la pologne
nous avions acheté des places pour un
train qu'il devait partir il ya une
heure mais s'est avéré que les billets
ne compte pas qui est tout le monde va
attendre dans la même que
[Musique]
nous espérions pouvoir aller facilement
en pologne
après dix jours où on se demandait où
aller vivre après qu'ils aillent les
explosions dans notre quartier de kef et
qu'on ait quitté la ville sous les
bombes
ça fait plus de huit heures qu'on attend
ils ont dit que le train partir est
bientôt mais personne ne sait exactement
quand est ce que ce sera
nous espérons bien sûr que la situation
en ukraine s'améliora mais nous voulons
que nos enfants aillent à l'école nous
voulons vivre dans le calme nous voulons
travailler et faire ce qu'on veut en
paix je suis venu avec eux le train pour
venir ici c'était très long et on était
assis mais enfin on est arrivé c'est
l'essentiel
[Musique]
devant la gare un groupe d'étudiants en
médecine nigérian évacuer des soumis
dans le nord-est de l'ukraine ils n'ont
pas souhaité parler devant la caméra
mais semblait partagé entre l'espoir de
pouvoir revenir rapidement au nigeria et
l'espoir de pouvoir un jour revenir a
soumis continuer leurs études